hey guys this is des the fan I think
here and I'm David Griffin resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the walking dead season
4 episode 12 still yes still on still
watching so yeah this is an episode
before I had seen it I've gotten a lot
of messages on facebook and i sent you
rather angry test and twitter about like
basically nothing really happens I mean
there's a few defenders and I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with
liking this like if you liked the
episode you like to have yeah exactly
however I'd say most people that I
talked to didn't care for it including
yourself and myself and I've been pretty
harsh on the show all year but like talk
to you and then other people you know
Michael here I'm think heroes well who
was more of a defender of the show and
they didn't like it either so I don't
know if I if they don't like it and I
really did like it um you mustn't really
not liked it because they kind of did
what you wanted to do because remember
you were talking about like I just want
to see Darryl and Beth together right it
goes like what do you wanna go and then
so they can do it quite is true like I
would have liked a little bit of being a
little hypocritical because I wanted the
walking dead a video game I wanted
Clementine and I wanted you know I
wanted that kind of a stories like I was
cooled and somebody said that there
might be a romantic relationship with
them but I'm like I think the actress is
kind of young yes I'll think she's even
a team a v8 anything even do that I
don't think that's not it's not going to
happen though she's too young but that
kind of wanted that little
father-daughter or big brother I just a
big brother little sister kind of
relationship and they got they gave us
that but like it just took to long for
them to develop story I mean yes the
ending was touching scene Gerald
breakdown Gerald's it's a good actor in
a good job in the scene we've complained
the past they didn't develop Beth enough
hey they gave it to us they're
developing Beth and I feel bad saying it
like the episode because like you said I
asked for this but I didn't like what I
saw well you brought in like the
execution which is my biggest issue I
mean we've been talking about this
before we're walking dead recently and
you know I compare it to the lost
syndrome where it's become so successful
they need to stretch out as much as they
can and so they're taking
bits of I'm not saying there isn't
character development in this episode
I'm saying is they have a little bit and
they just stretch it out right we did
not need the first 20 minutes to be
about Beth getting her first drink and
she ain't drinkin no peach schnapps oh
yeah Darryl I agree with their I'm glad
she didn't drink peach schnapps for her
first drink but we didn't need it to be
that long we didn't need it the episode
to be 45 min or 42 minutes are long the
running time is for Darryl to realize
that he's actually scared and fearful
you know you see he's got all these
emotions he SAT he misses his friends
like she said you just see me you know
they're dead girl that was a touching
scene dinner actor did a Dixon actually
I'm sorry not supposed ammo Norman
Reedus Norman Reedus at a great job
acting that out but we did not need to
wait 42 minutes to get to that seen it
just took too long I I think that's was
my issue of like why are we spending so
much time in the golf shop and this
girls like no rich [ __ ] on it it was
like that is that it just took too long
yeah a whole lot of nothing I think the
show she thinks it's being deep yeah and
that's what bothers me I think the show
really thinks it's being like it's going
like deep character study in this I'm
like you're not really doing it watched
you want to see deep Kirk setting watch
true detective this show is not doing
yea orsa true detective or something
like Boardwalk Empire where camp are
they weave the character development in
through the plot right we're there's
still story going right because people
complain about how slow boardwalk empire
is and it is a slow-moving show but with
the characters and the plot it's all
moving along slowly right but you can
still see it where this is ok this is
the character development episode well
let's just stop the plot right just you
write this long stretch out thing we're
really that could have been like 10 15
minutes yeah probably the one of the
best shows in recent years and it's on
this is breaking bad a lot of character
development while moving the story along
this show just yet like it had it feels
like you said it has suppose like it has
to stop and just stop everything can't
move the story along we have to just
focus on these two characters for 42
minutes or if watching with commercials
an hour and it's just too long it was
just just dragged out and it really
bothered me because I like these actors
I like the actress who's playing Beth I
like Norman Reedus I think he's a good
actor I'm not upset with a casting she
the execution is just poor I thoughts
for I actually afterwards after their
big break down hit a nice conversation
no as well but after that I did not like
how they burnt down the place that was
just stupid to me it was laying burn
this mother down yeah that's what why
why what's the purpose I don't
understand what what the purpose was and
then whole flipping off whatever
whatever you know I'm giving life off
and like what is what is this like the
early 2000s with like Eminem or
something yeah right already a little
finger up um yeah I don't know this this
episode just felt off balance to me you
know I've been kind of you know you guys
have heard me plenty times over and
again don't take this personally if you
love the episode this I said love the
episode if you liked it defend it love
it it's just my opinion but yeah that's
not this episode rubble the worst of the
season actually it's just not weeding
stuff whenever we talk to her we
complain about the governor episodes
yeah it wasn't so much that what they
were showing was like necessarily bad
but they just they would have been
better off weaving that storyline in
true and then it would have actually
helped out both storylines cuz remember
we had the the whole story lines of yeah
yeah the thing he had the governor stuff
like just weave that stuff in right and
this is the second week in a row that we
didn't see Tyrese I mean seeing last
week either and the girls I mean that's
a thing like this I'm fine with
character development for Beth I mean
Beth needs it that's really neat I mean
after season two when she was in the bed
the whole season I mean she definitely
she definitely a character development
so I'm fine with that I'm fine with
Daryl getting his time to shine but
maybe bring Tyrese in like it could have
cut back to Tyree so we didn't need 42
minutes dedicated just to bath and
Darrell I was a little or at least have
that they're gonna do that have them do
something besides get a drink and then
burn a house down and then I really
didn't like that that ND and like I said
I am tired and I apologize for saying
this guy no the show's gonna do I'm
tired of seeing people get angry at
zombies just sorry oh true to that it
happens I mean every few ever see two
episodes when did it
uh it's like I get you're angry hey I
get us the apocalypse life sucks right
now but if I see another seam looks like
hammer and just like sort like breaking
down I race did it it's just do
something new that works for a time but
like do something new I mean I don't
know I'm sorry it's I was all up so i
sent dead johnson angry text about the
episode i was forewarned about this
episode so but even watching i was just
like okay this is not it's not doing
very much for me that's why i think i
get so you know and i'll get some
criticism from time to think here open
which is fine i understand people are
past people love this show show is the
most-watched time on television I get it
but at the same time it's like i want i
don't know i wish i'm so passionate
about the show because i think it could
be good i think it could be a better
show than it is and that's why I think
expressed anger towards it i'm not
trying to pick on it let's take a
picking on the biggest show on
television but i want it to be good i
think it has a cast and it has the look
it's just I think this is the third show
runner on right now I think it's just
doesn't have the direction for it for me
the season or the series had peaked the
end of season two early two thousand
three after especially after Shane was
gone first part of season three was good
they like the first part yeah the first
half of season three is really good and
I like the second half of season two you
know I felt like you know with the shame
character they took it to its logical
conclusion right but yeah now it's it's
more of a show for me where it's like oh
here's a year's a good moment and then
there's like 15 minutes of nothing and
here's a good moment here just like you
know here's an episode that's not that
great and here's another episode that
was a lot better right and I feel sad
for the show in a way now I don't I
shouldn't feel sad that she was making
millions of dollars if I if I don't stop
watching the show that show was going to
go on and it's gonna do very well for a
very long time no matter what I say but
it's like you look at shows that have
stable show runners and do well Breaking
Bad had been skilled again madman has
matthew wine or you know battlestar
galactica has Ronald D Moore I mean all
this you know betting often wise for
Game of Thrones it has stable leadership
this show does not have stable
leadership I think it's certain to show
right now alright alright guys so that's
all we thought of this episode ah let us
know what you think did you find it
boring or did you find it really
tension-filled and exciting and let us
know in the comments below on think
caricom or on our youtube channel think
aeropro you come also find us on twitter
want to come yell at dennis or myself a
this is the free is the internet's free
world you can do it you can find this at
think hero i'm at griffin de we also
have a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think Carol fans and make sure you
like that page and if you like our video
share it on Twitter and Facebook if you
don't like it you know do something
you